saying like what didn't they it is risky
why would you say it's worth it
well
the social issue of i don't know well
child-rearing it's better to be in a
committed relationship together
um
that's why you know if you divorce it
significantly impacts the children um
psychologically emotionally all these
all these things so why would they do
that when most women will give kids
without marriage
that's also not good that's the thing
like you shouldn't you shouldn't be
going around getting
what about you guys what do you think
can you repeat the question
do you think it makes sense for average
men to get married in 2022
um
[Music]
i think everyone's entitled to do what
they want okay so
i don't really have an opinion on that
but personally if i was to ever
consider that i would prefer to get
married
okay do you understand where the men are
coming from though when they say yeah
yeah yeah
it's riskier now for them yeah you
understand that okay what about you
um
for the average man i mean
i mean if you haven't got much to lose
then i don't see what the problem is
really because what is the woman going
to take you for the kids do you have
your kids
well yeah but
it would be beneficial for them to have
their dad in their lives so why would
you take the kids away from that because
women are crazy
i mean how how much those are how much
of women are actually crazy though
there's a lot
actually
honestly honestly let's let's ask the
guys i date them what percent of women
do you think are crazy
honestly
no honestly honestly what percent are
women to the extent where they wouldn't
allow them to see their dad
this is okay i i would say i would say
i would say about 15 to 20
and the reason i say that
is because i think the more attractive a
woman is the more likely society has fed
her ego in certain ways which promotes
the craziness
but i think women who deal
uh who
kind of understand how the world works
more reality as opposed to that hasn't
happened to them i think they're less
crazy
for me from a woman's perspective
you can tell when a woman's crazy
like there's a there's
there's a way there's a look in their
eyes that the guy they're with they
can't tell like i've told my brother i'm
like there's a look in her eyes like she
is mental but here's the thing you look
again you're looking from a woman's
point of view we pick up on more social
cues than men do so for example if we
see a girl giving us a dirty look at the
bar
men don't see it they're like what are
you talking about she just looked at you
for a second but we're like oh no
you're you're ready you're ready to
fight over one look and then you're like
this is crazy
she's taking off her ear
so so it's for us it's easy to see yeah
but for men
they don't know they're just like oh
boobs
okay i'll probably maybe say like
30 30
crazy what do you guys think i would i
would have said about 15 20 as well you
know i don't think that many just based
on the women that i've i know in life i
i genuinely
first the women that i know i don't
think any woman would hold a would hold
their kids away from the father by the
way but yeah i would just say percent
for the sake of arguments i might be a
bit controversial on this one i would
say hundred percent
you know
that's why
it is a state of flux they are crazy
always it's just
they have different scenarios in which
they can be crazier or less yeah i don't
know if you guys have ever seen the
crazy to hot chart
yes
and so women are always at a baseline of
about four crazy anyway at all times
and then have the hot crazy line in
which you can then ratio the hot you
know you have the hot about eight or
nine hot but about maybe ten crazy or
eight crazes what you really want the
ideal scenario is a woman woman's about
an eight hot and about a maybe a six or
seven crazy a unicorn well no the
unicorns are about a four hot uh or a
three a five hot and and a nine crate
sorry a nine a nine hot and a five
crazy that's a unicorn uh anything below
that like it said in the hot crazy chart
uh there was a guy who had a woman who
was like a three crazy but a nine hot
and apparently that was probably a
transsexual because that that doesn't
exist it was probably a dude
that's a dude it's not a man it's not a
woman because such women do not exist no
i mean on a serious level though but
women i think baseline are always
because of the flux because of the
natural hormones that are running
through you every month every 28 days or
whatever it is yeah a woman can be
insane
sorry
oh you would say yeah what do you what
do you think ash um i totally have to
agree with what you've just said
i couldn't have said it better
yeah there's a flux where um
some women you'll never get to see it
most women it pops out from time to time
and you don't know where it's come from
um
but yeah
100 of women
so anywhere from one and five to a
hundred percent is what the men said
fair enough
it's like if you have to go into
something where you have a one it like
one out of five women might take my kids
are you gonna sign up
and i don't i don't like this reality
because i've always like my parents are
married i think it's better for kids but
like i can understand why men are
walking away
if the laws are literally paying you to
leave
can i ask a question yeah go ahead
uh
right so i understand how important
marriage is to you
would you still
want
um
marriage
if it was the way it was 120 years ago
so
you don't have the right to your own
money your own assets you are literally
the property of your husband who you who
has chosen for you his shuttle right
and your job is to stay in the home look
after house look after the kids
under those conditions and circumstances
would you still be in favor of marriage
the way you are today
if i had that mentality sure because i
wouldn't know any different today
the mentality and awareness you have
today
i'll just say maybe i won't say yes
so i think you know how you're like okay
under those conditions because those
conditions don't really favor you you're
a bit retracting from i can't
not the way it does today okay
right yeah you're kind of retract you
kind of retract a little bit away from
marriage i think that's how a lot of men
are looking at marriage like in the
conditions that it is today
they're retracting they're like this
isn't a good thing for me does that make
sense yeah because the thing is i think
i think most young boys they do grow up
thinking they're going to get married
like i think most of us do think that
because we kind of said this is what you
do
we're told of marrying the perfect girl
blah blah blah
but i think as you know like i said you
know what i mean reality hits a lot of
men hard the reason why i say
yes ish
is
the way i want to live my life is like i
want a homestead
i want to live simply and all that stuff
like what is a homestead
like um when you just have a house and
you have a bit of farmland just not not
a lot of acreage or anything and you can
grow your own veg be sustainable by us
you know
live sustainably okay yeah
yeah that sort of thing so it's not i'm
not too far away from it obviously the
being chattel that's obviously
that's why i'm ish
i wouldn't say yes today but of course
like i'm kind of there it's like very
trad yeah
sorry i just got a question um
i don't understand how is it that
marriage equates to stability i don't
understand that because you can have a
man and you can be with him for or even
a woman and be with her for 50 60 odd
years and never get married and that
will be your rock you'll secure your
provider you're not going to raise your
family have your homestead and do
everything but you're just not married i
don't understand why
marriage seems to be
a way to secure
the fact that you're with your partner
because historically it's worked better
that way compared to other versions of
um other family versions out there has
historically the government pending
marriage this is why i'm not yeah yeah
it's it's a government thing the whole
quantity of marriage is government it's
nothing to do i'll tell you i'll tell
you why though like in general because
women fear being left after we lose our
agency
that's why it's like it's like women so
that's why women hate when um gary v
his wife that
gary when garyvee left for the younger
model basically or maybe she left that i
don't know what happened but everyone
all the women on social media were so
mad because she gave that man her the
most valuable thing she has which is her
looks and her best years
and then
so women are afraid that they leave and
they get nothing out of it basically and
they invest in a guy i'm not saying it's
right or it's wrong i'm just saying that
it is what it is i just want to put a
note out this concept of monogamous
marriage this is a relatively new thing
in human history majority of i mean
human they estimate maybe human beings
have been around for let's say 200 000
years
majority of that was either polygamous
or
um men were just single there wasn't
very few people this this concept of
single one man one woman thing this came
out of
uh sort of religion a lot of religion on
organized societies and it's only a few
thousand years old at best maybe maybe
even ten at best it's not the norm